sie sind aber hier bei uns weil wir über
das wohnen sprechen wollen denn viele
menschen befürchten dass sie sich jetzt
in dieser energiekrise das wohnen nicht
mehr leisten können dass irgendwann die
gasrechnung ins haus flattert und dann
nichts mehr bleibt für die miete wie
soll ich mir jetzt also meine wohnung
aktuell noch leisten dass die große
frage heute bei uns hierbei bitte lies
haben sie auch manchmal das gefühl
gehabt irgendwann mal in ihrem leben
jetzt wird's knapp mit der miete jetzt
kann ich mir die nicht mehr leisten ja
klar als ich junge studentin war war
häufiger die frage wie macht man das
alles mit geringen einnahmen
glücklicherweise war das damals als ich
jung war noch so dass dieses mietniveau
in potsdam sehr gering war aber das ist
in den letzten jahren stark gestiegen
auch weil der staat über jahre zu wenig
investiert hat zum beispiel in den
sozialen wohnungsbau damit gerade junge
familien damit studierende damit
menschen mit geringem einkommen eine
bezahlbare wohnung sind das haben wir
jetzt geändert deswegen 70 überhaupt
hier deswegen gibt es wieder eine
wohnungs ministerin weil wohnen ist eine
große soziale frage unserer zeit wir
geben eine rekord summe aus 14 5
milliarden für den sozialen wohnungsbau
aber das braucht natürlich bei so ein
haus gebaut wird das dauert natürlich
eine ganze zeit deswegen haben wir jetzt
auch parallel gesagt das wohngeld eine
ganz konkrete unterstützung für viele
die ein eigenes haus haben oder eine
miete und die sich das nicht mehr
leisten können das wird deutlich
gestärkt von jetzt 650 tausend
haushalten auf zwei millionen und dann
auch und das ist auch neu mit einer
dauerhaften zuschuss für heizkosten ich
will ihn dazu was zeigen vielleicht
können sie damit was anfangen blenden
wir mal ganz kurz ein das sieht nach
ganz großer mathematik aus und zeigt mal
kurz ist das hier kennen sie das können
sie damit was anfangen
das sieht ein bisschen aus wie die
rentenformel ist aber wahrscheinlich die
berechnung des wohngeldes das ist sehr
gut können sie das sind schon fast 100
punkte aber könnten sie noch weiter
erklären wissen sie was man da einfügen
muss bei ihm zum beispiel und bei y also
was soll ich damit alle die zuschauen
jetzt keine angst bekommen das gehör
nicht ausrechnen um wohngeld zu
beantragen
wir machen jetzt ein sehr einfaches
verfahren für die wohngeld beantragen
dass man quasi nur nachweis muss wie
hoch ist die miete und die nebenkosten
und wie viel verdiene ich diese
berechnung von dieser komplizierten
formel die basiert auf der tatsache dass
in deutschland das mietniveau ganz ganz
unterschiedlich ist also wenn sie zum
beispiel in frankfurt alle oder eine
wohnung haben die 800 euro kostet bis
das relativ viel wenn sie in münchen
eine wohnung haben sie mir bleibt euro
kostet freuen sich total besoffen sie
das hier ist eine ganz einfache formel
machen ja wo wir sagen also miete ist
800 euro und der rest rechnet sich ab
dann haben wir quasi ganz vielen
geholfen in frankfurt oder und niemand
geholfen in münchen und deswegen gibt es
sieben unterschiedlichen stufen und das
bildet sich in dieser formel ab die aber
glücklicherweise weder jeden tag die
wohnungs ministerin aber auf gar keinen
fall die menschen aus rechnen müssen die
wohngeld beantragen und wir werden ja
aber die behörden müssen es machen das
wird kompliziert genug da die behörden
die sind glücklicherweise mit unserem
austausch dass wir das wesentlich
einfacher machen als bisher und es sind
auch viele bundesländer schon dabei dass
sie den online antrag gemacht haben so
dass das dann der freund computer
ausrechnen und nicht mehr der
sachbearbeiter mit dem rechenschieber
also jetzt sind wir gewachsen ist und
das y
dann muss ich jetzt sagen das kann ich
ihn soeben einmal in der monatsmiete und
y das haushaltseinkommen also ja es ist
doch demnächst bei ihnen auf dem
schreibtisch landet also ich hatte ja
gesagt formel ist im vertrag das haben
wir schon und unsere nachkommen erkannt
und ich habe ihm gesagt dass es vor
allen dingen darum geht zu sagen dass
man weiß wie hoch die miete ist ganz
einfach ruft die das wollen natürlich
hunderttausende jetzt in deutschland
wissen denen den sie auch gerade hier
nochmal bei bild live versprochen haben
dass jetzt eine wohngeld erhöhung und
eine erweiterung des personenkreises
jetzt aus steht die eben wohngeld
beziehen dürfen bis zu zwei millionen
haushalte sagen sie bis zu zwei
millionen wohngeldempfänger 97 vermuten
andere kunden ein haushalte die 1
millionen haushalte also noch mal mehr
wohngeldempfänger dann wann ist denn
klar wer wohngeld und in welcher höhe
bezieht wann kommt das gesagt wir
arbeiten wirklich intensiv daran und
mein vieles das wir ende september damit
ins kabinett gehen können und dann
stehen die eckpunkte fest und dann kann
sich jeder auch darauf einstellen
wichtig ist das natürlich das
gesetzgebungsverfahren schnell durch den
bundestag kommt so dass unser ziel dass
das zum ersten januar 23 in kraft tritt
auch erreicht wird das ist für
gesetzgebungsvorhaben dieser größe die
größte wohngeldreform seit bestehen des
wohngeldes sehr sehr schnell weil wir
wissen natürlich die leute warten die
haben soll und dann muss auch schnell
was getan werden wenn sie auch bei den
einkommens höchstgrenzen etwas tun
derzeit liegt das ja beispielsweise pro
monat bei 986 und dann bei zwei personen
bei
1348 zusätzlich auch der klar weil sonst
könnten wir die ausweitung ja gar nicht
und machen und inwiefern also viermal
glauben wie gesagt sie haben die
vorbilder gezeigt man kann jetzt nicht
sagen so ist es genau soll das hängt
davon ab wo man wohnt aber in etwa wie
mindestlohn verdient oder eine höhere
rente hat in dieser höhe der kann
anspruch stellen und mit der ausweitung
bekommt ja dann auch etwas wir haben
auch unsere zuschauer gebeten ihnen frau
gallwitz fragen zu stellen und das ist
die erste zuschauerfrage meine frage
wäre warum kann man die mieten nicht
einfach deckeln kommt immer wieder auf
der straße in dem fall von matthias
platz der hafenarbeiter ist mit seinen
58 jahren das warum nicht einfach die
miete decke dann habe ich sicherheit als
mieter ja aus sicht der mieter ist das
eine nachvollziehbare forderungen werden
sie allerdings der vermieter sind und
eine gedeckelte mieter haben und bei
ihnen die kosten steigen wir jetzt
gerade der fall ist dann haben sie
natürlich irgendwann die situation dass
sie sagen also wenn jetzt was in dieser
wohnung kaputt geht und die neue fenster
oder eine neue heizung brauchen dann
kann ich das nicht mehr investieren weil
ich habe ja quasi keine gestiegenen
einnahmen das ist das eine und das
andere ist natürlich dass wir noch mehr
wohnungen brauchen der größte investor
in dem bereich das sind die privaten
immobilien entwickler und die brauchen
natürlich auch ein gewisses plus was sie
machen können damit wir quasi diese
interessen ausgleichen können zwischen
den mietern und den vermietern gibt es
bei uns das soziale mietrecht es gibt
eine begrenzung zum beispiel die
mietpreis bremse das heißt die höhe die
erhöhung ist reduziert aber es gibt halt
keinen deckel viele vor allem familien
haben vor allem ein ziel rauszukommen
aus der miete in eigene heimat zu
bekommen und viele schaffen das nicht
mehr und darauf zielt auch die nächste
frage ab einer unserer zuschauer marcel
36 jahre alt ist lehrer und sieht für
sich da kaum eine möglichkeit das für
seine familie aufzubauen
ja ich bin beamter möchte mir ein
eigenheim zu legen und kann das mehr
oder weniger nicht finanzieren und meine
frage wäre wie jetzt für meine
generation der mittdreißiger eben es
ermöglicht werden kann was die
generation vor mir sage ich mal doch
leichter geschafft haben und ich sehe da
halt ja keinerlei möglichkeiten das
würde mich sehr interessieren
ich hab die generationen das davor
leichter hatte da würde ich jetzt auch
mal ein fragezeichen machen also wer
sich noch an die höhe der bauzinsen in
den 90er jahren erinnert die waren
deutlich höher über dem was heute
passierte und viele familien haben
natürlich jahre lang gebraucht sich
eingeschränkt wenn ich in urlaub
gefahren wenig konsumiert um dieses
eigenheiten dann auch finanzieren zu
können das was wir jetzt machen ist ab
oktober zum beispiel eine unterstützung
von menschen die nicht in der stadt ein
eigenheim bauen wollen das ist
unrealistisch aber zum beispiel
genossenschaftsanteile erwerben wollen
und dann in ihrer genossenschaft leben
das unterstützen wir erstmalig auch mit
einem förderprogramm und wir konzipieren
jetzt für das nächste jahr eine
unterstützung für familien die wir
gerade gesehen haben mit einem geringen
einkommen die dann auch eine
unterstützung des staates bekommen soll
um sich eigentum an zu schaffen aber
klar ist natürlich ein haus zu bauen ist
es für viele die größte überhaupt
vorstellbare investitionen in ihrem
leben und man profitiert im alter davon
wenn man selber immobilien hat aber das
heißt natürlich für viele jahre das man
sich auch einschränkt jetzt sind sie ja
bundesbauministerium und nicht bundes
nicht bau oder bundes planungs
ministerin 400.000 wohnungen haben sie
hat die regierung hat die ampel
versprochen zu bauen wo stehen sie da in
diesem jahr also ich bin auch planungs
ministerin unser haus ist auch zuständig
für die raumordnung des natürlich die
grundlage für alles was da volk und im
baugesetzbuch diskutieren wir ganz oft
die frage wo kann man dann überhaupt
bauen wo es erlaubt zu bauen und das ist
was der stark machen kann ist ja nicht
so dass wir eine staatliche
bauverwaltung haben und jetzt
1000 pro jahr wo stehen sie ich hätte
eingangs gesagt wir haben zum einen den
zuschuss deutlich erhöht das muss man
machen weil man sonst bei den jetzigen
baukosten keinen niedrigen mieten hat
die 14,5 milliarden für den sozialen
wohnungsbau und wir reden jetzt im
bündnis für bezahlbaren wohnraum welche
regeln wir ändern müssen damit schneller
und unbürokratischer in deutschland
gebaut werden kann zum beispiel die
digitalisierung dass es digitale
bauanträge gibt das dann nicht mehr die
aktenberge durch soll es klappen wird im
ziel
da muss man wissen wir kriegen die
baufertigstellung statistik immer erst
im jahr darauf im mai da kann ich ihnen
das haarscharf sagen wir haben jetzt
einen bau über haben das heißt
genehmigte wohnungen die noch nicht
fertig sind von 847 1000 also zwei mal
so viel wie das ziel von den 400.000 ja
und wir gehen davon aus dass etwa
500.000 davon jetzt im bau sind wie viel
dieses jahr fertig ist hängt von
unglaublich vielen faktoren ab wir haben
natürlich jetzt durch den krieg durch
die sanktionen aber immer noch auch
durch carola liefern ihr material
na ja umso mehr schaffen sie das ziel ja
oder nein das wird man exakt feststellen
können im nächsten jahr aber wir müssen
natürlich sehen dass die
rahmenbedingungen momentan für alle die
auf den bau tätig sind sehr sehr
schwierig sind deswegen haben wir
unterschiedliche maßnahmen geschaffen
zum beispiel ein ganz also ich sie haben
ja die lange formel gezeigt werden wie
lange worten eine stoff
preisgleitklausel also dass die firmen
zum beispiel nach verhandeln können also
sie den hauben chancen ab sodass er
kennt ja moment jeder der ein haus baut
das ist halt so schwierig ist da kommen
im moment die höheren zinsen an den die
quere und da kommen die kommt die
materialbeschaffung geben die sie
angesprochen hat in die wäre genauso bei
ihnen das heißt sie rücken schon von den
harmlosen die aber das nützt ja nichts
wenn ich sage jetzt ist alles so
schwierig dann lassen wir das deswegen
auch nicht von ihrem ziel ab sondern wir
müssen gerade jetzt den druck nutzen
dass wir sachen machen die in den
letzten jahren liegen geblieben sind zum
beispiel die frage der kompletten
digitalisierung des ganzen
planverfahrens aber natürlich auch die
steigerung der produktivität auf dem bau
also wie viele bauarbeiter schaffen wie
viele häuser weil wir natürlich auch
einen großen fachkräftemangel haben den
wir auch in den nächsten jahren auch
wenn wir die regeln für das einwandern
erleichtern nicht einfach lösen können
das heißt wir brauchen mehr computer
mehr roboter auf unseren baustellen und
wir müssen zum beispiel auch das
serielle wohnen unterstützen gleich da
und denken ja manche sieht dann aus wie
in den siebziger jahren in ostberlin das
sieht mittlerweile sehr
individualisierbar aus den häusern sie
sind nicht an dass die industriell
vorgefertigt werden aber das schafft zum
beispiel die möglichkeit mit mehr
produktivität mit weniger bauleuten mehr
herzustellen wir sprechen auch hier
übers klima und das ist vielen
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern vielleicht
nicht sofort bewusst was hat das wohnen
überhaupt mit dem klima zu tun was kann
ich was soll ich überhaupt mit meiner
wohnung tun um das klima zu schützen
schauen wir auf etwas was sie dazu
gesagt haben sie sagen wir müssen die
frage verstehen nicht nur verstehen was
hat man es war halten schauen wir hier
mit dem klima zu tun weshalb man
verkehrsverhalten damit zu tun sondern
auch die frage verstehen dass
individuelles wohnen etwas mit dem klima
zu tun hat das bedeutet man sollte sich
übersetzt das mal im platz beschränken
je kleiner desto besser das ist erstmal
nicht der ansatz aber ich mache mir ein
praktisches beispiel weil abstraktes
thema total viele kennen wir jeden fall
die gegen ganz fleißig ins fitnessstudio
und dann trinken hinterher ein
weizenbier und essen schnitzel und
wundern sich warum sie nicht dünner
werden und so etwa ist das mit unserem
gebäudebereich wir schicken seit jahren
den gebäudebereich ins fitnessstudio die
heizung werden immer effizienter die
fenster sind immer dich da wir machen
diese riesen
materialien ran aber die co2 bilanz des
gebäude sektors ist immer noch schlecht
warum ist das so weil die fläche die wir
selber verbrauchen die wohnfläche dies
gestiegen von 25 quadratmeter pro person
nach dem krieg auf jetzt fast 50 so wir
verhalten uns also wie derjenige der ins
fitnessstudio geht und hinterher bier
trinken ein schnitzel ist schon jetzt
ist die frage was machen wir denn da und
da ist zum beispiel ein schlüssel die
multifunktionalität also wenn sie jetzt
hier so ein haus haben und haben sie
lauten 2 und raum wohnungen und 15 jahre
später braucht man aber ganz viele viel
raum wohnung weil jetzt die familien
alle kinder gekriegt haben dann hat man
ein problem ja so und wenn man jetzt
beim planen daran denkt dass man die
häuser so flexibel macht dass man das
dann gleichzeitig berücksichtigen kann
dass man sie schnell umbauen kann dann
ist schon viel gewonnen und natürlich
die frage mit welchen materialien bauen
wir weiter den weg nach ganz schön aber
bedeutend wie machen wir auch eine
holzbau strategie genau den leuten zu
sagen überlegt doch mal ob du wenn du
warst nicht auch gleichzeitig co2 ist
heute haben viele auch alle die selber
bauen auf dem schön dass man da durchaus
bei den materialien was tun kann
47,4 quadratmeter das ist der
durchschnitt seit fast fünfzig die er
jedem bundesbürger derzeit zur verfügung
steht das also zu viel also das handbuch
zu erklären ja und das ist ja auch wenn
man sich das anliegen da verstehe ich
aber das bedeutet wir müssen kleiner
werden aber nicht unbedingt sich also um
es mal klassisch zu machen ganz viele
mit familien mit kindern leben auf
kleinen wohnraum wenn ich zu wenig
häufig und je älter man wird desto
größer wird doch maja aber wenn es in
der summe gleich bleibt die einen ziehen
um und die anderen landes beim selben
ergebnis sie wollen ja insgesamt runter
sie wollen ja
klimafreundlich sozusagen wohnen das
heißt sie müssen runter von den 47
quadratmetern zurück vielleicht zu 25
mal ein ganz einfaches beispiel wenn wir
beide uns jetzt entschließen würden
einfamilienhaus zu bauen für uns und
unser geschäft
dann ist das wunderbar 150 quadratmeter
fünf personen sind wir weit unter diesen
50 quadratmetern wenn unsere drei
kindern aber ausziehen dann hört mal
kinder
quadratmeter also und dann sitzen wir da
und haben ganz großen verbrauch müssen
das heizen und brauchen die fläche
einfach nicht so wenn wir aber gleich
sagen okay unsere kinder werden
wahrscheinlich und weil ausziehen wir
machen links einen eingang rechts und
eingang und in der mitte lassen wir so
eine trennwand möglichkeit 110 dann
können wir dann zusammen links wohnen
und rechts vermieten oder eines unserer
kinder zieht dann da ein ich dachte
schon sie sind beide dann in getrennten
so war ich hoffe du sagst du würdest du
denn das sei jetzt ein abstrakter also
einfach dass man darüber nachdenkt dass
häuser in ihrem lebenszyklus auch
unterschiedliche phasen haben und dass
man natürlich
einfamilienhaus über 20 jahre gut
auslastet danach er nicht und dass man
das beim bau berücksichtigt das ist
etwas was wir unter multifunktionalität
verstehen und das kann dann auch dazu
führen dass wir den wohnflächen
verbrauch reduzieren ohne dass
irgendjemand sagt er muss ich jetzt
einschränken wurden sie dann auf großem
fuß oder haben sie schon verkleinert
also ich bin in der situation dass ich
mit meinen drei kindern und meinem mann
in einer wohnung wohnen und das ist dann
natürlich deutlich unter dem
durchschnitt verbraucht der bundesrat
stehen nicht ganz für sich alleine
47,4 quadratmeter zum einen den frage
ist was passiert wenn meine kinder
ausziehen aber das ist haben wir eine
lösung gefunden
ich überlege mir ob ich das angebot aber
und komme gegebenfalls sehr gerne darauf
zurück danke herzlich für das gespräch
frau ministerin bei wird es an diesem
tag der so ernst ist frank ja eine neue
eskalation in diesem putin krieg bringt
danke ihnen frau
[Musik]